Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
in the book of
purification
regarding the chapters of bathing
In Alwaji,
we have arrived at
the most important part or one of the
most important parts of this chapter
which is the description
of the prophet sallall.aii wasallam's
the way that he would most commonly make
on occasions the prophet sallall.aii
Wasallam when unable to perform
his usual due to illness or what have
you, he would
resort to the most minimalist
which was
making sure that the water poured over
the entirety of his body.
most notably near the end of his life
when he was ill
and bedridden with the illness that
had later claimed his life.
However, this is not how he would
usually make listen.
Just as we had the most
well-known most widespread
description or comprehensive description
of his wudoo which is the narration of
which is the basis of
the descriptions of his wudoo in the six
books the six mother books of hadith
chosen by those authors.
Likewise, the most comprehensive
description of hisul is the narration of
and this is as well the narration which
is chosen by the authors of the six
books of hadith regarding
the
[Arabic recitation]
she tells us that when the prophet Sam
usually would bathe
his bathing for janaba, he would begin
with washing his hands.
So he would use his right hand to pour
the water into his left hand and then he
would wash his private parts. Then he
would make woo as he would for salah.
Then
he would take the water in his hands and
work the water into the roots of his
hair.
And when he felt that he had worked
the water deep enough into his hair,
remember he usually had braids and so he
would work the water under said braids.
They were not very very tight braids.
They were rather loose braids. He would
then pour the water three times over his
head and then he would pour the water
over the rest of his body. in other
wordings his right side of his body and
then the left and then he would wash his
feet. So let us review how this woo or
how this would look, excuse me. He would
begin.
It's not coming out of a
shower head, right? So it's in a it's in
a kind of
a kind of open container, if you
will, usually about this big. or if
it was big enough to pour this or
he would hold it, it was small enough to
hold and he would pour it into his hand.
So he wouldn't put his hand into it,
okay? Because he hasn't washed his hands
yet, right? So he would start by using
his right hand and pour the water into
his left and he would wash his hands.
For us, we don't really have this issue.
We just turn on the faucet, right?
I guess the closest thing to that or
the closest equivalent would be us
turning on the faucet with our right
hand. And so he would wash his hands
three times and then he would wash his
private parts. Then he would make his
full woo as he would for salah. How did
he make wudoo for salah? He starts with
his hands and then mouth and nose and
then face and so forth. And then he
would work the water into his the roots
of his hair as best as he could.
And he would then pour the water or
rinse his head three times and then he
would wash the right side of his body
and then he would wash the left side of
his body and then he would wash his
feet. The reason he left his feet to the
end is because there was no drain.
Right? So the place where he washed is
where all the water is. In other
narrations, he would change places and
then wash his feet. Again, we don't have
that same dynamic. So what do we do? We
can when we make the woo
for salah we can make the woo for salah
including the feet or leave the feet
till the end. Both is okay and both is
correct
and then he would have concluded
his
also tells us in another narration in
Muslim
This is an interesting addition.
Aisha says the messenger of Allah.
Wasam would noticeably not make wudoo
again after he finished his.
meaning the in the way that I just
described to you that is his
why would you need to make again you
just made
you just made
and so this would be his woo because it
was made in this way but the details of
taking the place of
are details that we will arrive at later
on inshallah t I want to remind everyone
of something and that is that the
purpose of these
talks or these
discussions is for us to learn new
things. Right? Imagine if I sat here and
taught you only what you already know.
What would be the point of us?
absolutely nothing. We would need to
collectively, me included, get someone
else to come and teach us. That's the
point. So sometimes old habits are hard
to break and sometimes we have a kind of
adverse effect to new knowledge, new
things that we haven't heard. However,
that is the whole purpose of this.
Otherwise, this is just a feudal
exercise and intellectual flexing. That
is not the point of this. The point is
when we hear something new, we try to
put it into action as best as we can. As
best as we can. As we mentioned before,
the the the
advice of the scholars
is to never hear a sunnah and completely
abandon it. Even if you're unable to
sustain it all the time,
try your best
that if you only can implement 20% of
the time or 30% or 40 that we do this.
Never do we hear a sunnah or know a
sunnah and abandon it for someone else
to do, right? Because then we all start
to assume that the other person is doing
it. And what kind of people are punished
by Allah? The kinds of people who do not
have any of the prophet amongst them.
[Silence]
and this is why the issue of which
medab says what this is usually an
exercise
in futility. It's not really an
important issue. This is an issue dealt
with by students of knowledge, by
scholars when they wish to arrive at
conclusions and doublech checkck
conclusions and so forth. This is for
their debates. Our purposes is the
prophet did the prophet said, "Well,
what about if he did that but it was
abregated or he did that and it was
meant to be done a different way." the
percentage of that of his sunnah which
was abregated
or
redone or eliminated is an entire a
an extremely small amount.
you could probably gather all of
his abregated actions or narrations
in probably
less than 50 narrations.
That's it. Because abrogation is a very
oneoff, very out of the ordinary thing.